it's on the house desean hang in there
more guys life is a nightmare
try to clean house but the dirt runs
deep here yes the east winner will be
announced at the annual nfc feast
there's likely to be a team with a
losing record what if a super team
stole the nfc e spot there's technically
nothing in the rulebook that says you
can't
delaware clams assemble
[Music]
you want cmc to join fake team it's time
for a recruiting montage
yes let's go we're looking for elite
players oh
yeah i'm in it's tj hawkinson from the
lions
you guys came to me right right uh do we
have to include a bengal
sneakers heard y'all needed a coach the
goals just seemed so legit they just
hand us the trophy
what is it surprisingly great race from
state farm
wait doesn't everyone get this
[Music]
oh who are these newcomers hello i'm bb
volt i hate children and following your
dreams oh god i'm lying and i feel
terrible about it have we breached their
security yet let us
eat computer hacking into mainframe oh
well you have football jerseys so sure
come in
okay young way go charm everyone alright
right upright
i like you backs are you in position
dropping the jag to get the bag
oh no my leg may or may not be cramping
my apologies fantasy managers luckily no
one seems to be paying attention to
james robinson it used to be the
connectivity clams before me spam told
sold us out clean exchange ready to run
hello nfc east wyatt so inspiring
last few weeks we've been hot the giants
us the clams i guess
uh well we're nine and five we played
the bagels and jags and stuff oh god am
i addicted to lying
and the winner of the division the clams
look i never doubted the old zack back
here for a second
wait you never doubted an nfc's team
that doesn't seem right hey wrong
get him yippee young way mother i got it
jalen don't run no no let him he knows
how whoa
are you really going to attack me feel
good story alex smith
no here man dad i'll hit alex smith to
get back in the dance
tv attack unleash clammy tv is getting
it together our
turtle turtle clamboys
hi i'm carson i play for the eagles are
you sure you
[Music]
hey clam fam clever here to announce
that you could buy delaware clam shirts
in a bleach report shop
now you can wear something that will
make you constantly have to explain
oh it's the joke from a web series so
yeah
you'll look pretty cool and if you buy
enough shirts they will free me back
into the ocean